[Music]
we um over the last few years there's
been sort of a almost like a cultural
battle around the fbi and intelligence
agencies uh the fbi much maligned by
donald trump and trumpists for its
allegedly politically biased involvement
in
electoral politics even though if you
actually think back to 2016 the fbi's
involvement
may have been what handed donald trump a
victory remember james comey's second
completely unnecessary press conference
about the investigation into hillary
clinton's emails but let's put that
aside for now
um modern day
we have seen the fbi become a flashpoint
of controversy uh particularly in the
context of the january six riots there
is now a blockbuster new investigation
from the washington post
which shows that actually the fbi
received very specific tips
about the violence that was expected to
happen on january 6th which did remember
the day of the trump riots but the fbi
as far as the washington post has
uncovered declined to act
this is
stunning
this is stunning let's look at some of
the information a sprawling new
investigation by the washington post
into the events leading up to the
capital insurrection
has revealed that the fbi received
numerous and highly detailed tips on the
potential for serious violence by
followers of then president donald trump
on january 6. and despite the
specificity and volume of reports the
fbi largely dismissed the warnings
the fact that law enforcement of all
stripes reportedly underestimated the
likelihood of violence on january 6 has
already been widely reported but the
post's massive project started last
spring based on interviews of more than
230 people describes in excruciating
detail just how much was ignored
in one of the more shocking revelations
the post recounts how information began
flooding in to the fbi as early as
december 6 when the agency received a
tip about a message in an online post
telling trump supporters please be in dc
armed on the six
you might have to kill the palace guards
are you okay with that and indeed there
was violence against the so-called
palace guards u.s capitol police there
to defend the capital another message
reported by the post stated in an
apparent reference to killing officers
drop a handful the rest will flee
meaning
kill a few u.s capitol police and then
they're going to get out of our way
on december 19 trump tweeted a message
exhorting his followers to come to dc on
january 6 writing quote big protest in
dc on january 6 be there will be wild
that lit up online pro-trump groups and
fbi informants quickly began passing on
information about highly specific
planning for a violent attack in
washington here's how the post puts it
the fbi received a call alerting them to
trump supporters making plans online to
bring arms to washington and arrest
lawmakers
that the sunday afternoon call was
handled by the bureau's national threat
operations center a clearinghouse for
tips about crimes according to a
document titled threats to take guns and
overrun the dc police january 4 to
january 20th
it's almost like the 911 memo bin laden
poised to strike
threats to take guns and overrun dc
police
the file was updated the following
afternoon by an fbi employee seeking to
reclassify the information more domestic
terrorism than criminal in nature they
wanted to say hey this is almost not
even just criminal this is domestic
terrorism criminal has received a number
of guardians as a significant number of
guardians as a result of threats to
congress and other government officials
the caller according to the fbi document
said people were planning on meeting in
certain areas
and sneaking guns into dc in an attempt
to overrun the dc police beginning
january 4th through 20th on three
different sites there is discussion
about recruitment where to meet at bring
guns and arresting senators and members
of congress to hold trials outside in
public areas in one specific threat utah
republican senator mitt romney often
regarded by trump supporters as a
traitor to magda
was named as a target
yet despite all of this on december 22nd
the post says the fbi
closed its internal threat assessment of
the matter determining it did not
warrant further investigation at this
time
an fbi official told the post that
before doing so steps were taken to
share the info but ultimately the
determination was made that the tips
they received featured vague and
primarily first amendment protected
speech
when we think back and we say
how were they not more ready
and why was the national guard not
deployed in advance and even as the
capital was being overrun
and as we follow the chain of command
upward we learned that on the day of
it was donald trump who was reportedly
gleefully watching the first couple of
hours of the riots maybe thinking it
would actually prevent joe biden from
ultimately being certified as president
of the united states
later trump started to not really like
that the rioters looked low class and
made him look bad
but the pressure was building for him to
deploy the national guard he was told
mike pence is potentially in danger mike
pence had to be evacuated they were
chanting hang mike pence but we know
that trump was actually mad at mike
pence trump was furious that pence
wasn't willing to do what trump believed
pence could do to really stop the
certification of joe biden as president
even though pence accurately told him i
can't do that sir i can't do that um and
the calls built for trump to call off
the protesters and to send in the
national guard and it was trump who
resisted doing that on january 6th but
this is a much broader backstory of a
sort of hot potato that was being played
behind the scenes the fbi
was at the time that they could say this
is criminal not domestic terrorism
sort of letting the dc police know you
might want to do something about this
the fbi was saying to department of
justice
uh you know maybe you need to look into
this and coordinate fencing or whatever
the case may be
capitol hill police seemed
not to actually even be told what the
fbi was aware of and then there was this
last minute request for national guard
which was initially resisted although
ultimately the national guard was
deployed and there are some people who
are writing this is just like what
happened on 911 where agencies couldn't
communicate they couldn't coordinate
there weren't systems in place but this
is actually a clearly different thing
after 9 11 systems were put in place so
that different agencies could coordinate
with each other
this seems more that there was a lack of
willingness to do those things for
reasons we don't yet totally know and
possibly because somebody ordered them
to stand down so let's uh i will now
explain to you
the more benign explanation and then the
the really horrible one
the more benign explanation here
is
the fbi
genuinely
didn't think
that there was the potential for january
6 to become what it was and they made a
mistake in judgment they didn't take it
seriously enough now what's interesting
about that is that it would sort of run
counter to the idea that the fbi and all
of these intel agencies and others were
out there to make trump look as bad as
possible and all these different things
it sounds like you know if the fbi
wanted to make trump really bad they
would have publicized this in advance
they would have made trump's look bad et
cetera they didn't do that
the sort of sinister possibility for
which we don't yet have evidence right
these are the speculative ideas
is that someone
once they caught wind that the fbi was
receiving these
threats information about these threats
and starting to act on them someone told
the fbi stand down
turn this over to someone else sort of
but don't really give him much
information because we want the riots to
be able to happen because we think maybe
they actually will stop the
certification of the election
we don't know the answer to that yet but
every week we are getting more and more
information about the fact that many
people and by people we mean elected
officials
associates of trump
and law enforcement had reason to fear
that this was going to get really really
bad on january 6 and it did
and the right preparations were not
ultimately in place at some point we may
know the full story we still don't know
it as of right now